let's hear now though from our second
speaker for the motion for Hana you mean
she's an international environmental
lawyer and activist with extinction
rebellion she was a negotiator on the
Paris agreement with the small island
states in April last year she was
arrested after gluing herself to shells
headquarters and she's a co-author of
this is not a drill an extinction
rebellion Hamburg
well thank you very much there's a lot
in what Adair Turner has said that I
agree with and we must accept that the
solutions to preventing climate chaos
preventing climate carnage actually
exist they exist today most of the
technologies that we need to use to
bring emissions under control exist
today I think what capitalism doesn't do
is deal with the social injustice --is
that are already happening with the
global warming that we've committed to
and that will continue to rise should we
also miss the 1.5 degree target and go
over shooting beyond that at the moment
we have a kind of capitalism that does
not look after any of us
it doesn't look after the people in the
UK it doesn't look after the people
overseas it doesn't look after the
planet it does not look after nature so
I feel that maybe to add to George's
definition of capitalism a simple way is
maybe to see capitalism as a pyramid of
extraction
that's what capitalism is it's a pyramid
where people and nature are at the
bottom and profits and wealth and power
accumulate towards the top they've
accumulated in such obscene quantities
that they threaten the very nature of
our democracies there used to be a
tenuous kind of link between capitalism
and democracy but actually that link
isn't really true and if anything that
link is going in the reverse direction
so why did I choose to speak for this
motion why did I choose to join the
rebels back in April I've got two books
here and it's not because I want you to
buy them and sell them and buy this one
by the way because all the profits go I
want you to this is a climate change in
carbon markets book that I wrote and
came out in 2005 when he spent the first
decade of my life as a climate change
lawyer negotiating the UNF CC the
climate convention and then the Kyoto
Protocol and
protocol gave rise to carbon markets
which were also developed in the
European Union so I've got quite a lot
of you know history of being into the
very kinds of regulations the very kinds
of incentives the very kinds of market
mechanisms that Adair has said can
constrain capitalism can constrain and
control pollution and that's twenty
thirty years later I have to say those
mechanisms do not work they don't work
all of the experts have now agree that
using emissions trading for a structural
problem like climate change does not
work we're not talking about an end of
pipe what we call you know fix-it
solution a technology that we can just
use and ask power power stations for
example to bolt on in the way they did
with sulfur we're asking for an entire
rejigging of the global economy of every
country's energy system of every
country's agricultural system of every
country's transport system of every
citizens aspirational desires that is
what we call a systemic challenge that
is the carbon economy that we need to
change and we cannot regulate it simply
by looking at all the technologies that
are available and saying somehow
magically the system will adopt them I
think the the my disillusion slightly
you know intellectual as it was with the
kinds of mechanisms that we were being
urged to put forward as solutions really
came to a head as it became more and
more clear that the influence the power
the preponderance political power of the
biggest corporations in the world
all of which trade in in carbon
intensive products oil gas coal you name
it those are the biggest ones those
companies whether they're state-owned or
privately owned those were lobbying and
controlling the sort of narrative and
greenwashing
and actually heavily influencing the way
in which elections take place you see
that very clearly behind the scenes if
you're a day-to-day lawyer as I have
been in the in the climate regime you
see regulations being vetoed watered
down you see permits that were meant to
be constrained given out for free being
given out in excess which means that
none of these mechanisms really worked
my final trigger for gluing myself
tishell was really a report that came
out which said that since the signing of
the Paris agreement in 2015 1 billion
dollars had been spent by the top five
oil companies in the world on lobbying
and marketing and greenwashing that was
for me a really important sense of
outrage that I felt I don't know if you
can see this here but this is like a I
don't know if you could see this tiny
sliver you know someone served you that
as a cake slice it wouldn't be a slice
it would be a sliver that little tiny
orange sliver is the slice of funding by
the oil majors that goes into low carbon
and green sources of energy all of the
rest this is a 20-19 figures goes into
still digging out exploring and
producing yet more fossil fuels the
scale of these destruction is immense
Saudi Arabia Saudi Aramco which is the
largest most profitable company in the
entire world produces a profit of around
three thousand dollars per second around
300 million per day so trying to control
and regulate companies as large as that
essentially is a geopolitical challenge
it is not a technological challenge we
have to find a different system for
constraining these sorts of dynamics and
I feel that's what we haven't really
understood
I want very much to say that there is a
level playing field and somehow the new
technologies that Adair has talked about
which are there most of them by the way
will emerge they won't they won't
because the largest share of government
handouts what we call fossil fuel
subsidies just call them for what they
are government handouts are being paid
to fossil fuel companies still because
they have political power and control
the scale of those subsidies is mind
boggling so there's two ways of counting
these subsidies if you include the cost
of actual damage they come to like five
trillion dollars that's an obscenely
huge amount that means that these
companies are being supported by
governments and they have taken control
of the economy in ways that does not
lend itself to a sort of reformist
mindset that's why I think the young
people and people who are really active
in in politics are coming up with much
more radical solutions so I don't want
to leave you with a lack of hope and
lack of alternatives
I think big business especially big
business and finance the UK is at the
heart of the global finance industry our
need to be absolutely controlled with
regulation we need to say stop funding
and financing these activities we need
to say to our governments very clearly
stop using taxpayers money to support
and subsidize these same industries we
need to say to the CEOs of these
companies and the finance industry you
are failing humanity we have to make
very clear that what they're leaving us
with is the challenge especially to
younger people of reversing this
cataclysmic breakdown they're leaving
the burden of coping emotionally
physically mentally and rebuilding
institutions of trust because young
people and people all over this country
is
especially those who have not gained
from globalization not gained from
capitalism no longer trust governments
and no longer believe that we can bring
prosperity in the way that they have
been led to expect I think it's very
important to accept that the public
actually have a visceral understanding
of the failings of capitalism and have
already rejected it that's what's
happening it up and down the world
whether you look at the the Chilean
miners who have rejected and their
people in Chile who turned out in their
Millions these relations you know
there's a the student strikers
everywhere you look there is an outcry
and a desire and an appetite for huge
amounts of change I think what would
really help is a structural 10-year plan
you can call it the green New Deal the
nature New Deal something like the
Marshall Plan that was done after the
Second World War to bring together to
bring societies together to look
globally and to make sure that we put in
place a system which is akin to the
match national health service and I
would call it the natural health
services what we now need for the whole
planet
you
[Music]